- [Interviewer] All right, Jillian.
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Jillian,
where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- [Jillian] I'm originally
from Bremerton, Washington.
It's a small Navy town
in Washington state.
- [Interviewer] And tell
me about your childhood.
You had both of your parents?
- My mom had to work two jobs
cause my dad refused to work.
My dad was very, very abusive.
I was abused when I was eight
he molested me when I was eight.
He raped me when I was
sixteen and he pretty much
terrorized me, my mom and my sister.
A lot of abuse, a lot of
taunting and stalking.
And, you know, he made our life miserable.
- [Interviewer] And nobody stopped it?
Or nobody gave any regard?
- Well we filed charges
when I was molested,
but I guess they had
them do some kind of test
but he didn't meet criteria
for his rights to be taken.
So we still had to see him.
And my childhood was just,
it was just basically
always in fear, always in fear of my dad.
Always just sad and scared and
always unsure of myself.
- [Interviewer] Sounds awful.
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Interviewer] And then
where'd your life go
after you left home?
- Well, I got married when I was
eighteen or when I was twenty
and everything was fine for
almost like eleven years.
And then I left, got
back into doing drugs and
I completely went,
I completely lost my mind, you know?
I became homeless for the
first time in my life.
I lived a very sheltered life.
Like I was never exposed to drugs
or being homeless or anything like that.
You know, I started prostituting myself.
And to try to keep him in,
cause I wanted him to be with me
and I felt like if I could bring
him money and get him rooms
and all these things that
he wouldn't leave me.
And of course it didn't matter.
Cause I was always by myself, you know.
You know, men are, you know, a big problem
for me because I seek that love and value.
But I think it's love and validation where
it's not, you know where it's just about
sex and what they want from me.
And I've learned to be okay with it.
I learned that I know I
probably do have value
but I don't see that
inside myself, you know?
- [Interviewer] Were you doing drugs
before you got married?
- [Jillian] Yeah, I started
using when I was fifteen.
I tried meth when I was seventeen.
It was the first time.
Everything escalated after
my rape, when I was sixteen.
You know, I wanted to escape from my life.
I wanted to not feel.
I wanted to feel numb, you know?
- [Interviewer] What is your drug today?
- [Jillian] It's still meth.
- [Interviewer] So you're
living now on Skid Row?
- [Jillian] No, I was
living out in Long Beach.
I kind of bounced around
between Long Beach.
You know, I haven't been
out here in a minute,
but I was, you know,
going in this trap house
in South Central, but mainly
it's been in Long Beach
but I started like losing my mind
like convinced, like, you
know, people want me dead
because I was messing with
dudes from different gangs
and people have told me like,
that's going to get you caught up.
And, so it's like everyday I'm in fear.
Like something's going to happen to me.
Always in constant fear.
- [Interviewer] And what does,
So what are you doing for money now?
- [Jillian] I still sell my ass.
I still prostitute myself.
For a while I wasn't doing it and then,
I started doing it again, so.
- [Interviewer] And that
gets dangerous, right?
- Yeah. I mean, nothing crazy like
where I've been held at gunpoint
or like what I hear other
women have gone through
or worse, but you know, for me,
it's going to that fucking level
of giving myself to someone that
I normally wouldn't, you know?
So, I dunno.
- [Interviewer] Do you have
contact with your family still?
- I talked to my mom, I check in with her.
She's very disappointed and
hurt and she won't see me.
I don't talk to my kids.
You know, my daughter, my oldest suffers
with depression and she has
a lot of suicidal ideation
because of the fact that
I'm not there, you know?
So, I dunno.
- [Interviewer] So
where's your sister today?
- She lives with my mom.
She doesn't talk to me either.
So it's just basically
me, you know, my friends
like they don't reach out to me.
The friends that I've had
in recovery off and off
in the last couple of years.
- [Interviewer] Oh you've been through?
- Yeah. I've been in recovery
in the last eight years off and on.
- [Interviewer] Have you been clean?
- Yeah. The longest
amount of time I had was
almost a year. I went out like two days
before my year and that's
what I consistently do.
I'll get almost a year
and then I'll go out.
- [Interviewer] What typically
triggers you to go back?
- Relationships.
- [Interviewer] I'm sorry?
- Relationships. I'll
get in a relationship
It won't work out.
It just, it hits me to a
level where I can't take it.
I can't take the pain.
So I resort to, I start hooking up
and then the hooking up
leads to me using again.
- [Interviewer] Do you
see your relationship
with your father as a big part
of why this has all come about?
- I blocked out what my dad did.
I never really dealt with what my dad did.
I mean, in my addiction,
like I've had countless men
like rape me and do some
fucked up shit to me.
And to me, I feel it
comes with a territory.
It's like, I can talk about being raped
and it's no big it's
like, it's no big deal,
you know? Because of what I do,
you know, but with my
dad, like, I don't know.
I think it's like, I still
carry that pain, you know?
- [Interviewer] What do you wish was,
I guess my question is what do you
wish for your future?
I mean, do you have any plans?
Do you have any goals?
- It's hard to see like past,
like in this moment, you know
my thing is always, I don't
want to be on the streets.
I don't want to be around
anyone that's gonna
fucking hurt me.
Like, I'm always convinced people
are gonna fucking hurt me you know?
- [Interviewer] So you're
just living day by day.
- Yeah.
But you know, when you go there, like
I know like this isn't
going to last forever.
I know.
Like I want more for myself.
I want more for my children.
Like I want to be there for them
and having them know that
I love them you know?
I just, you know, I want to say that
like I wanna stop and I
wanna live differently.
I wanna live my life,
but my addiction has such a grip on me.
It has like a rope around my neck.
And it like controls
every aspect of my life.
And it's like, I've lost
sight of everything.
- [Interviewer] All
right. Thank you so much
for sharing your story.
- Yeah, you're welcome.